sorry for the English I'm French that's
a disclaimer hmm how can a man that has
not grown up with the confidence and
trusting male role models and mentors
sort of anti Uncle Jake person's only
intellectual I'm saying this without
disrespect to these people how can they
become a confident man and develop the
necessary man skills quote unquote okay
it's interesting you can say man skills
in quotes yeah and I think we pretty
much know what that means right yes like
what that means so so how do you do that
you don't have any positive role model
around you that's like an uncle Jake
which by the way most people don't have
an uncle Jake Yeah right that's not
normal to have Uncle Jake most people
you got what you got and in this case
he's saying he's got like the
intellectuals so you know oh my parents
were college professors and they don't
have any of these skills and they sit
around and talk about philosophy right
now I ended up I can talk about
philosophy well but I can't fix my car
yeah or I can't defend myself yeah in a
combat scenario in the streets so what
are you gonna do okay this is real
simple go do things mmm go do things
lift start lifting weights learn how to
deadlift learn how to squat that's
that's part about being a man right sure
physically yeah physically strong learn
some jujitsu
I recommend that probably could have
guessed that one yeah learning how to
fight learning how to defend yourself I
just got asked us the other day kid came
up to me he's like what should I do if I
get intimidated by other people and I or
I don't know how to react when people
like get in my face I said do you train
jujitsu no start training in jiu-jitsu
mm-hmm but then what I'm gonna fight
everyone no no you don't have to because
you already know you can beat them up
right now if they attack you yeah you
can beat them up but if they are just
getting in your face and trying to Punk
you and you look at them and go hey if
you want to do this let's do this but I
don't care yeah I know you can come to
my gym I'll talk you out train some
jujitsu so we got
that one run hike sprint climb build
things start building things rewire
things do some plumbing these things are
not they're not impossible to do now
it's gonna take you longer right like
I've rewired my parts of my house
I've replumbed parts of my house we've
done all the plumbing in parts of my
house now if you watch a skilled
electrician do what I'm doing it would
literally take him 1/8 of the time maybe
1/4 of the time because or like the
drywall over you're talking about
earlier a good drywaller they are like
masters a good electrician masters a
good plumber they're smooth me it's
gonna take a while sure so but but what
I'm saying is it's not impossible yeah
it's not impossible to do mmm and it'll
take you more time but you're learning
how to do it and that gives you what
does that give you it gives you the
self-reliance right hey I can fix my
electrical outlet if I need to yeah so
those are good things that work on your
car change your oil whatever do those
things and and again those things like I
so I took electricity class in high
school sure where we learned how to wire
rooms and everything is that what it's
called elec it was called electricity
class I took electricity with Scotty was
the teacher's name sure wait you called
him Scott everyone called him Scotty he
was an older guy his name was Scotty we
all call him Scotty so Scotty but we we
learned how to walk wire houses and all
that well I didn't remember any of that
when I was now 20 years later or 15
years later I'm rewiring my kitchen
where I which I ripped out of my house
okay so what did I do you know what I
did
went down to Home Depot mmm I bought a
book called electrical wiring and I've
read through it and I'd followed the
directions
same thing with plumbing go down by a
book called how to do plumbing and you
do it and it and the good
thing about this stuff is it's very
satisfying to do that kind of work yeah
it's very satisfying to do it and you
can over engineer things you make things
super solid in your own house secure
yeah super yeah you can just kind of go
the extra distance because it's your own
your own house so that's cool so those
are all physical things and some kind of
knowledge things that you can start
working on what the hardest thing to
overcome here is like a level of
embarrassment yeah right how so like I
don't know anything about wiring oh yeah
yeah you know I don't know I'm
embarrassed to say I don't know anything
about wiring yeah
and so people don't want to say anything
so they'd rather just say hey let's get
an electrician in here to figure this
one out yeah
or hey I was good yeah so they're too
embarrassed but if you have time do it
yourself yeah and don't be embarrassed
about it be like hey I'm where I'm
rewiring my kitchen to have no idea what
I'm doing yeah give me this book yeah
what do I need to get Oh give me some
tools it's good to have good tools yeah
also so that's that's like I said those
are things that you can do you know um
learn to shoot you know learn to shoot
that's a good good skill to have also
read write read about history read about
survival read about the world read about
human beings under duress read read
books good books about good stuff about
challenges it's and then just like Mark
and we're the warrior kid he doesn't
know his times tables yes to learn them
you have to go learn all this stuff and
talk about you have to go learn and with
with time your confidence is gonna grow
and from humility you'll grow into being
more confident now you also say you
don't have any mentors or role models
around you that's okay because those
mental mentors and role models are in
books and you can find them you can I
just talked about david hackworth
good mentor to have a met and you can
have a guy a guy wrote you a 1000 page
book on how to lead and it's for you
that's pretty awesome
beyond band of brothers my dick winners
mm-hmm
guess what here's a guy that was that in
charge of the band of brothers in
Normandy and he wrote a book for you to
learn how to lead so those are some
examples and like I said most of the
books that we've covered on this bar
many of the books that we cover on this
podcast give you a mentor better than
anyone could possibly hope for
yeah so you can get it there but and we
mostly cover war books but there's books
about all kinds of people that can be
virtual mentors so read study do do
that's my advice on that one yeah that
physically strong thing is a in my
opinion a big deal
because especially what with you know
intellectual types in that kind of
environment
yeah since that's not really a priority
a lot of the time you tend to you know
how like you're not into something so
you kind of shun it you know and I've
seen this I'm not saying all the time
but you know sometimes the inner I don't
like takedowns so I'm not gonna do it
yeah and then you think of all the
reasons why you don't need to do it and
how guys focus true you know or whatever
so in an intellectual circle will say
yeah those circles sometimes you'd be
like oh yeah those meatheads or whatever
you know they just don't shun it or you
say about that issue
no yeah but they'll do that yeah and
then there'll be these physically frail
people but since they they're in their
mind smarter than everyone I feel like
they have the one up in there kind of
there's an element of satisfaction there
yeah but at the end of the day you're
physically weak there comes down and I
think most of the time I think I don't
know but it seems like most of the time
they'll have these feelings like this
guy asked right here like yeah man how
can I develop because I feel it yeah
yeah unless they just want to be in
denial right that's what exactly a ban
and also he'll and by the way the same
thing happens in the reverse right yeah
guys it's just
meathead he shuns and and disrespects or
disregards the intellectual side of this
and that is that is equally as bad
because they're not they don't know
what's going on they're not
knowledgeable they're not learning they
don't understand the world in a clear
way so find the balance between those
two things
yeah what's great is those things are
not mutually exclusive like you don't
have to just be a meathead or just have
to be a bookworm right you can do both
there's plenty of time in the day to do
both
Leigha a smart ass guy with a big
deadlift
that's a good thing I'm trying to be
that guy
yeah not there yet but I'm not working
on it yeah and then that one level up
which is the jujitsu part of it you do
think you are thinking about jujitsu
combines the intellectual piece with the
physical piece yeah and in a way you can
connect I'm not recommending this at all
in fact I'm against this but this is the
nature of jujitsu you don't have to be
that like you don't have to have a big
deadlift to dominate in GG first you
don't have to do any of that so you can
essentially overcome the physical part
of it even though just is physical but
it's a you don't have to you know
overcome a physical part of it for it to
a point yeah yeah in everyday life I
mean you you're trying to you're trying
to be the guy like if someone's better
than you at jujitsu training room it
really bothers you are you talking about
everyone or no me you doesn't bother me
well let's say it motivate I don't know
you know like like it doesn't bother me
right right right I mean like for
instance I trained with Dean Lester all
the time yeah he's better at me in
jujitsu right I everyday wanna train
with him right so it doesn't bother it's
not bother but like what I know compels
you like impels like no no maybe it does
like I hate it at the appends on what
you mean by mother I hate it I do I hate
it and I love it and we were just joking
about the other day because we got into
a little scrap
yesterday you know kind of into training
and all of a sudden things got escalated
and there was some shouting going on and
shouting shouting yeah yeah you know he
was saying what he says and I was saying
what I say and but we had a you know we
had a mutual truce at the end we
I think he didn't really want anymore I
didn't really want anymore so we just
kind of let's let's laugh and call it
good because you're rolling the dice
when I'm alone with Dean there's a dice
roll happening because if he ends up in
a good position on me there's gonna be
pain there's gonna be pain if I end up a
good position on him there's gonna be
pain so I think both of us we got away a
little bit unscathed neither one of us
got a really good position and we I got
back up to my feet and I and then we
both kind of just had a mutual agreement
an unspoken agreement yeah we were done
for the day
but the point there being is in almost
like in this weird way you know how like
intellectually you can excel so you can
kind of find it justifiable to avoid the
physical part of it it's almost like you
could almost say the same thing about
jujitsu you could still be effective in
defending yourself without be physically
strong necessarily but but my point is
that there's a limitation to that oh
yeah ultimately if you you can be you
can be unbelievable at jujitsu but if
you're really really weak and you go
against someone that's really good at
jujitsu but there are a hell of a lot
stronger than you yeah you're gonna have
some issues right yeah yeah I ideally
and that's ultimately the main point is
just like how intellectually you can be
you know a black belt and you can sort
in a way get away with not necessarily
being and vice versa and then Judas is
like that third element you didn't sort
of get away with not being super strong
but still be effective in drugs to you
know I mean so yeah ideally just like
someone in the middle yeah get that
balance here but being able to defend
yourself is a whole nother thing than
being physically strong you know seems
obvious but when you go through life I
think it's not because you get these
like big jack guys and it's like no one
wants to mess with him well bro this
medium to small guy who knows jujitsu or
knows these you know for real fighting
stuff is way more of a I was like
dangerous but yes ultimately way more
dangerous than this big jack guy who can
lift a lot for sure so it's that third
element that are kind of weird when you
roll with somebody that's super jacked
and they don't know jujitsu yes and it's
amazing
it's like amazing yeah you just think
yourself how is this happening
yeah this is the magical power yeah
because you look at a big jack guy your
human instincts tell you look out
yeah he's gonna that person is stronger
than you you know watch out
but when you know jujitsu yeah you don't
and eventually you realize you don't
even have that anymore yeah you know
everyone you're looking at thinking wait
you don't have whoa you don't have no
keen that is a fear
yeah instinct of fear although you're
still you you you know my first thought
when I look at someone's like do they
train or not yeah do they train or not
if they train we may have issues this
could be a problem if they don't train
no factor yeah no train no factor yeah
if they train may have a factor that's
why I got to work out hard so I never be
strong yeah yeah you know you know cuz
they might be coming to take my lunch
money maybe right don't want that no
how's this last night literally last
night I didn't train last night I did
not train last though we're a real world
experience so you know the five gallon
jugs of water
you know those Bing you put in the water
cooler or whatever so this like a little
refilling thing that I went to lay it
was like I've told this story before no
there's another this happened last night
so hazardous duty I know
water refilling of the joints yeah I do
that
okay last night when I was doing now is
refilling the jugs you know I go in
store I'm coming out walking to my truck
to get the empty jugs to go to the
little thing as I'm walking to my truck
a car pulls up right next to the water
filling thing mm-hmm there's a what's
called a red box you know what yeah so
car pulls up a kid maybe 12 years old
jumps out of the car he starts like it
was a yoked do it no normal kid whatever
and from in the car this thing male
probably is dead someone maybe stepdad
really and immediately the dad start to
yelling at him mmm
just put it in the thing and just to the
point where I thought it was kind of
joking where cuz all joking my daughter
like that
you kind of like hell you'll do
sometimes yeah yeah you'll get up but in
it sounded like a joke mmm when I was
like wow this guy's serious and the kid
is like you could tell he was kind of
used to it
no he was like I am I'm doing I'm trying
you know whatever whatever and they look
on the whole parking lot could hear ya
and this is at nighttime secure setting
so I'm walking to my truck I'm like bro
if I get to this place and this guy's
still there
not even yell arms in there I'm gonna
have to say something not be a dick I'll
be like hey don't talk to it like that
I'm gonna try to solve this problem be
like a this kitten you know whatever I
had this little thing before I knew
digits or anything like that I wouldn't
have messed with it I would even beam
like big or whatever in strong I would
have been like oh man that's yeah you
know but man I was like man I'm gonna do
this so I grabbed a and they left so I
didn't get the opportunity but I'm just
saying these are things that can happen
on varying levels every day yeah and if
you're in intellectual tec-9 and I'm not
saying if you're an intellectual but if
you don't have these elements of whether
it be skill or knowledge or whatever
like those things mess with you you know
I can't yeah and when I figured out what
jujitsu was when Master Chief Steve
Bailey choked me and he was he was an
old man at the time probably three years
younger than I am
and I was thinking myself this how'd
this guy just do this to me that's
insane that's completely insane I need
to learn whatever he knows you teach to
me whatever you know because I don't
want to feel that way ever brought and
then you're training it like let's say
you train for five years for five years
you're training not against people who
don't know you're training against
people who know you know dangerous
people who do know like how to defend
your shit and then you go in the real
world yeah you have this guy has no idea
how much control you have over an
internship yeah I see yeah that's it's
totally so yeah this this whole thing
were I mean year and that your thing
about some guy was the guy was his
problem was like when people get in his
face or whatever his problem wasn't
getting beat up it was when people get
in your face and how you react in the
right feeling right off Brad that
feeling gone yeah because you're right
your numbers are right because he said
he wasn't scared of fighting he was
saying like I might get in trouble
Hughes he didn't like how he felt
I felt like he should do something and
he felt like a lamp basically when you
know that you can destroy someone then
it doesn't matter you just think they're
an idiot yeah you beat them you get the
strength and the skills and you actually
beat them on an intellectual level so
it's like a day yeah yeah if you can get
those three intellectual psychological
whatever mental physical and skill wise
defending yourself that's the lit the
three right there
it's good stuff nots just just how hard
you want to hit it really you want to
hit it ours I think so too
you know it's very beneficial to hit it
hard